all right jack yes sir Jack uh where you
from originally where'd you grow up
originally I'm from a city called walam
Massachusetts it's about 12 miles west
of
Boston tell me about your
family uh I come from uh an amazing
family I grew
up so I was born in ' 84 I grew up with
my mother single mom and her parents
which were my G my grandparents and her
grandparents which were my
great-grandparents all in the same house
um so I got a few generations of of
learning in that experience it was it
was it was really nice I was very lucky
were you close to your dad I do not know
I do not know who I know my dad's name I
I never no no single mom and I'm an only
child just me and my mom wow my uh I was
I was brought into the
world so my mom story isn't mine to tell
but so I guess the best way I could put
it is
um my mother was not really a willing
particip participant in the creation of
me if that makes any sense it does by
keeping with trying to keep her
anonimity intact yep yeah so I don't I
don't know who he is I don't know um I'm
told that I look like him but I do look
just like my mom she's got a little more
facial hair than I do but we do share a
lot alike very fun
and tell me about your
childhood so I um I was very lucky I had
a I had a great childhood
um I made friends very easily with
sports
um uh I I think as far as Society is
concerned I I look pretty normal so it
was very easy to make friends um with
boys and girls
um again only child but I I I made
enough friends where I was never alone
um but yeah it was I had a very easy
early life it was it was very nice I was
treated very well by by pretty much
everybody that was in my life but you
had some rough spots too I did um it
wasn't known but someone that someone
that I cared about very deeply and that
also cared about me
um was behind closed doors some things
were going on and um
it's interesting I I don't I don't think
that what happened
was um intentionally hurtful I think it
was
more um exploration type of things um
but I was very young uh you know very
young so I have a 5-year-old son and I
was a little younger than him when it
started and it went on till I was about
12 um we both loved each other we both
knew that we cared about each other so I
didn't know that there was anything
wrong with it at the time until until
about sixth grade or so fifth or sixth
grade um when I realized that I was
interested in girls and not what was
going on
um behind closed doors and I asked them
to stop and it stopped so it wasn't once
he knew that it wasn't something that I
was was okay with it stopped so I don't
think I don't think that that situation
was
um the same at all as as what happened
right after that so I I went to middle
school and I was about 13 in seventh
grade and I had a teacher
um his name was Bob Daisy it's a it's a
known thing I had a teacher he was my
both my Drama teacher and my b baseball
coach
and that situation was intentionally
hurtful and
um that man changed a lot in my life
both for the positive and the negative
he did a lot of great things for me um
taught me how to be an actor in drama
class um helped me fine tune my baseball
skills he ended up being my my football
coach as well in high school um so there
there were a lot of positives again I
didn't have a dad so we did some things
that that I wasn't able to do with my
grandfather because my grandfather was
obviously quite old um so a lot of
um a lot of good came from him he helped
a lot of other people out but um he was
a predator realistically um and so
that he changed the tra trajectory of my
life in in ways that I didn't even that
I didn't know at the time um I've
actually never I've actually never spoke
about I have with with a couple
different therapists but I've never
actually spoke about um what happened
which which is I'm I'm okay with
speaking about it
um so when I was 13 I was in Middle
School
and this this this this man so I'm just
going to call him Dace that's what he is
to everybody and it's easier for me to
fluidly talk about it if I just call him
by name so Dace
um told me that he had a friend in
Providence Rhode Island that was
involved with um the mob and he ran like
a massage
p and in order for him to hire new girls
he would test them out on on people and
and so da told me that his friend would
send girls to DA's house and they would
see if they were any good at giving
massages so he said for Christmas he was
going to give me um a present and he was
going to have one of those girls come to
his house and give me a
massage and as a 13-year-old kid I
thought I was the man I thought it was
going to be the best thing that ever
happened to me so I I I said of course
that's
great when the time came um there were
rules so I had to um I had to be
blindfolded so that I could not identify
the girl if I was out in public with my
friends and I saw her that I could you
know point to my point to her and tell
my buddies that oh that's the girl that
this happened with so I had to be
blindfolded and um my hands had to be
tied so that I couldn't you know reach
out and grab her force her to do
anything which at the time made sense I
was a
kid um so I agreed that night um I I I
was tied to um bed posts and a blindfold
was put on me and uh I heard a car pull
up outside I heard D go outside and I I
heard him talk to another man and I
heard girls voices and then I heard um
somebody come in
and it was it was great I mean it at the
time I remember thinking that it was
amazing I got a like a full body massage
for an hour um with oils and it smelt
really good and I had never had anything
done like that before and then it turned
into it turned into a hand job and and
oral sex performed to me and which I
thought was amazing um I noticed 13 yeah
I was 13 so this was
like again so as a as a kid I had had
those experiences not with a
girl um so this was like I mean I was
elated I thought I I couldn't wait to
tell my friends about it um although I
wasn't supposed to but I remember
throughout the um throughout the massage
and stuff um I kept feeling like her
fake nails come off and like drop on my
chest or drop on my stomach and then she
would pick them up and stick them back
on which I thought I didn't think much
of it but I remember noticing that and
thinking that's strange you know like
why why doesn't she just have real
fingernails anyway it happened I thought
it was
great um she put my towel back on da
came in untied me asked how it was he
said it was great he asked what happened
I didn't want to tell him cuz I thought
it was like between me and this girl
couple months go by he tells me that his
friend reached out again and he wants to
send another girl and I said sure So it
happened again um this time while it's
going on right off the bat I don't know
if it was because I was paying attention
to it but I kept feeling her fingernails
come off and fall on me um and then this
time the person kissed me
and I I I couldn't tell if it was just
my
brain being strange but when they kissed
me I thought that I felt stubble like a
man a man stubble um I wasn't sure but
but I I it felt like it and my brain
told me immediately like you're crazy
just relax and enjoy the situation so
every all the same things happened and
it was cool it was a little strange
because the the nails thing and and I
and I thought I felt stubble but I
couldn't be sure um and they didn't try
to kiss me again after that maybe I made
a or moved away um so I I sh Shrugged it
off and um but it just left kind of a
weird feeling so a couple months went by
and da um at the middle school Dace told
me hey my friend has a girl and I was
like you know what the last time was
kind of weird I I don't want to do it
anymore and um I'll never forget he
got infuriated and um he had a
whiteboard in his classroom that he
would draw stuff on in classes and he
and he punched the Whiteboard board and
and broke a couple of his knuckles and
um just freaked out and and I couldn't
understand it and he said that I was
going to embarrass him in front of his
friend
um I was just very scared so I said I'll
do it this last time but it's the last
time that I'm going to do it so this
last
time I had to know I just had to know
what was happening so this time the
third time which would have been the
final time when he was putting I was
tied and when he put the blindfold on me
I made sure that I could see um and he
said you know can you see anything I
said nope so he leaves the room I hear
the people outside I hear girls outside
and I hear somebody come in the house
and
um I see that it is it's not a girl um
it is it is
Dace
and he's he's naked and he has a a
woman's wig on and fake
nails
and
so again at this point I think I was 14
so in an
instant I had to make a
decision do I scream do
I politely say da I see that it's you
can we can we not do this
um as a 13 or 14-year-old boy my best
decision
was
to act like everything was normal I
didn't know if he was if I told him that
I that I could see and that I knew it
was him I don't know if he's then going
to beat me you know rate me take it a
step further I knew what was going to
happen I was going to get a
massage and I was going to get a hand
job in oral sex and then it would be
over I knew that that was the extent of
the experience was it him the other
times as
well it was all
was the previous times that he arranged
this it was was it him yeah yes oh it
was yes so so I see now that this whole
time it has been him and that's why I
see his fake nails falling off and
that's why I felt stubble when they
kissed me
um but in that instant when I saw that
it was him that came in the
room I made the decision to pretend like
everything was fine um
immediately when he touched my body
somehow it was as though I was watching
it from from up in the corner of the
room and I didn't and I wasn't feeling
what happened I was like watching a man
give me a massage like my brain
protected me somehow and got me out of
the situation and I was just watching it
happen
um and I didn't know
that that decision that I
made to not do
anything would
confuse and change my life in in such
drastic
ways
um so the same things happened I got a
massage I I got a hand job and I got um
I had oral sex performed on me and I was
able to finish as though as though I
enjoyed it
that made me question everything about
myself because am am I gay which there's
nothing wrong with but I was able I knew
that that was a man and my body reacted
as though I liked it does that mean that
I like men
um because I didn't do anything does
that mean that I'm a coward because I
didn't stand up for myself do I have any
self worth
um all these all these things were were
born out of that one moment where I made
a choice to accept what was happening in
Fe because I knew the end result in fear
of the devil that I did not know I
accepted the devil that I did know and
it um it just it sent waves throughout
the rest of my life that I didn't know
was going to happen um but that is and
that's the first time that I've actually
described what happens to me everyone
knows something happened um but that
that is that is what happened and
then he was still my coach he was still
my teacher
um I got held back in eth grade I
remember he had told um some people that
I wasn't mature enough to go to high
school with the rest of my friends so I
ended up get kept I got kept back in
eighth grade and I stayed in Middle
School when all my friends went to high
school
and that was the first time that I lost
most of my friends um and then later on
in high school he was my football coach
when I was a
senior I went to my coach The head coach
and told him that something something
wasn't right I didn't I didn't tell him
exactly what had happened and this is
like a big this is a this is like a
serious a serious thing in the city that
I'm
from because people think that I went
and told him EX actly what happened and
he didn't help me and that's not what
happened I went to the head coach and I
said something has happened and I am
uncomfortable around Dace and I can't
play football anymore if Dace is still
going to be my
coach and in order for him to do
anything I would have had to explain
what happened and why I'm saying this
and I wouldn't so there was nothing that
he he couldn't just say okay you won't
tell me what's going on you're just
uncomfortable I'm going to tell that he
can't coach he wasn't capable of doing
that so without me telling him exactly
what happened there was nothing he could
do I didn't tell him that I was abused I
didn't tell him that I just told him
that I was uncomfortable around him and
asked him to keep him away from me and
he couldn't he was my football coach so
I after three or
four games that season my senior year I
quit football and that was the second
time that I lost a lot of my friends
because they asked me why and I said I
just didn't want to play football
anymore and they couldn't because I had
never told told anyone what happened um
so I lost a lot of friends that way as
well
uh but that is what started uh I guess
that's my childhood outside of that
situation that I just told you my life
was beautiful I I I I was so loved and
accepted by everybody I
although when I was
alone you can only be with your friends
and people that love you so much there's
always going to come a time where you
have to go home or or a time where if
you're at a sleepover everybody else is
asleep and you're alone with your your
own thoughts and feelings
and I was never I was never okay um I
was never okay with with with not taking
care of myself in that situation um and
it affected me I I became suicidal um
started writing a lot of really dark
poetry which I just assumed all all
young boys write horrible poetry when
they're young and um
but I
found
opiates and opiates saved my
life the first time that I took an
opiate that was not prescribed to
me I immediately
felt
like nothing bad had ever happened to me
when I walked in a room on opiates
go back when I walked into a room
normally um from age 13 to
19 I thought that you could see that you
could just tell by my face that I had
been sexually abused and that I was
damaged goods the minute that I took
opiates I somehow thought that that it
was gone I I don't know if it was I just
didn't care what people thought because
I was high but I I I I distinctly
remember the first timeing
opiates my brain telling me you finally
found what you need to get through the
the rest of your life on a daily basis
this is it this is this is what's going
to get you through life
and I no longer wanted to harm myself I
no longer wanted to take my life it was
like this
newfound zest to want to live as long as
I had opiates which at the time I I
thought was fine you know I I knew
people took opiates all the time time if
they had pain I didn't think it was a
big
deal you know I was 19 at that time fast
forward I'm 39
now I didn't know I didn't know the
impact that that opiates would have on
me I didn't know all the hurt that it
would cause
um that's a whole that's a that's a
whole another chapter of the strange
book
um my life could have been very
different maybe my life maybe my life
could have been worse
um but in a strange
way Dace made a
very
positive profound impact on my life
before that happened to
me if we were at recess and a group of
kids were teasing another kid I would
have joined
in um I wasn't always very nice if I
didn't need to be I wasn't very nice I
mean I was generally okay but
um after that happened to
me I knew what it felt like to be
helpless in a situation and be
victimized and it completely changed the
way that I treated other people and um I
would go out of my way to spend time
with people who others wouldn't I would
um like I said I I played Sports if one
of my sports
friend was picking on someone who maybe
was in choir
or uh you know some class that was
looked down upon for some reason because
the social situations in high school are
very strange I would I would stand up
for those kids and tell my buddies to
relax and and try to invite that person
into the Social Circle that that I was
in um so he had a very he actually had a
very positive impact on
me regardless of of of all the negative
that happened from it
um he made me a better person and and I
and I and I have to say that I'm glad
that that happened um I'm glad I'm happy
with who I am today it's taken a lot of
uh it's taken a lot of therapy and a lot
of treatment
centers to get to where I am today but
I'm I'm I'm very I'm very happy with who
I am and I'm convinced without him I
wouldn't be this good of a person does
that Mak sense yeah did it come out that
he was doing this to you it did did not
come out that it that was doing it to me
it came
out that was one of the tough that was
that was one of the tough facts of of
that the 11th kid after
me told someone a family member told
someone there there were how many kids
total I don't know it never came out
that there was anyone before me but
there were 11 after me W um he was
pretty good at what he did so I can't
imagine he would be that good at it if I
was the first one but I mean it's
possible but the 11th kid after
me told
someone about what happened and I don't
believe that the situation was the same
that I just described it could have been
but he told someone whether a family
member or someone that they said got him
some special sort of present or like
brought him to a strip club or however
he described it to make himself okay
with it um and that person heard and
that that loved one of his heard what
they said
and thought that it was strange and so
they went to the police and
um so Dace was arrested um cops two
detectives showed up at my house I was
23 two detectives showed up at my house
asked me um if I would talk to them to a
recorded statement and I did but in the
statement in that recorded video I told
them like listen I'm I'm high anything
that I'm about to tell you like I'm not
going to be any use to you guys have
been using drugs for the last four years
every day and I'm and I'm h oxycotton
right now I'll answer whatever questions
you want but this isn't going to help
you um so DA got arrested two weeks
before he was to go to
court he K they say he had a heart
attack
um someone got him a large amount of
heart medication that he took all at
once and so he took his own life in
prison two in a holding cell in
Cambridge Mass two weeks before before
he was to go to
trial um so he's gone I mean he's not
hurting anybody else but a lot of people
didn't get a lot of people have not had
the closure that I've had
um I had to I had to I had to reach a
pretty far bottom to get the closure
that I've had but I don't think a lot of
people
got what was due to them in knowing that
that
he that Justice happened
um but he's gone he won't hurt anyone
you know
uh it's just crazy because he did so
much good for so many other kids I mean
he was I think his uncle was like the
mayor of Wal him and when he was a kid
he was loved and that's why I didn't
really that's why I was really scared to
tell anybody about what happened because
anybody that I would have said anything
to would have said you're out of your
[__] mind and how could you say that
about such a good
man um or maybe they
wouldn't I'll never know um today he's
viewed differently because it came out
but
um it would be like you know be like if
I came to you and I was like hey man Tim
TBO grabbed my butt be like Tim tbo's a
great man what are you talking about you
that's just an example Tim tbo's a great
athlete I'm not saying I could I be like
me saying you know anybody that's well
respect yeah I saw I saw Jesus Christ
steal a candy bar like you know you you
just he was just a question that you he
he was a person that you didn't question
their behavior um so I didn't and and I
learned a very hard
lesson
um but that is what
fueled my addiction I don't think that's
what caused me to become addicted to
drugs but that was that was the excuse
that I held on to anytime a family
member a loved one a girlfriend a friend
were like okay man you know you really
you got to calm down and I would always
play the you know you don't know you
know you don't know what I've been
through you know if you had been through
what I'd been through you'd be doing the
same thing and I held on to that for for
years for years and and it was just it
was just an excuse that man did not
cause me to use
drugs I I found
drugs and they helped me they helped me
live
for for that period of time the drugs
saved my life until they started to try
and take it from me but at first without
opiates I wouldn't be sitting here
making uh making this this with you
right now um tell me where the drug use
took you so drug use took me it started
when started when I was 19 years old
when I graduated high school in 2003 I
moved to New York to be a to try and be
an actor and a model
and uh I lasted about 6
months the industry was tough wasn't
really my cup of tea and some of the
things in that industry that I
was whether I saw participated in was
asked to participate in but didn't a lot
of it reminded me of what I had been
through um so I came home after 6 months
with no uh with no warning I just came
home and and told my mom I gave it my
best try but it just didn't work out um
and I started I started
daily using oxycotton um you know I
dabbled with whatever I could but
marijuana and uh and oxycotton was my
jam eventually
oxycotton stopped coming
around um my grandfather died when I was
26 April 10th 2009 it was Good
Friday I have his name tattooed on my
back he he was he was everything to me
he was like my dad cuz I didn't have one
um bumper he died on Good Friday
2009 and I couldn't find
pills but I could not deal with his
services without opiates so I found a
person who had heroin where I'm from
it's not like California where I'm from
heroin comes in a powdered form it's not
the black tar that you guys get out here
um so I was just able to snort it
and same effect but that was my
introduction to heroin I couldn't find
pills I found
heroin um enough time goes by where you
snort and smoke heroin where it's it
becomes $5 $600 a day habit and then
there's always that one person I'll
never forget this kid we were going to
get some stuff and I told him how much
that I was doing a day and what I was
spending he like you could spend $50 a
day and get by you just need to do it
properly and um so I allowed him to do
that for
me and
uh I never went I never I never did it
any other way than than than IV after
that um any drug that I used if I was
you know cuz I I did my share of cocaine
and crack and and other things but from
that from that day forward I never put
anything up my nose I never smoked
anything it was always IV drug use it's
just I mean once you learn how to ride a
bike walking somewhere just seems
ridiculous it it's just it's just a
faster way to get to where you want to
be um so I ended
up you know to condense it I ended up
stealing from or
cheating um or lying to ruining a
relationship with anybody that cared
about me if you had my last if you
shared my last
name that was who I targeted the most
because um I when I use drugs I am the
epitome of a coward and a
snake I'm not like a tough guy who goes
out in strong arms dealers or goes in
Rob stores I manipulate and steal from
people that I love because with the
hopes that they will not have me
arrested because they love me um I was
that kind of drug addict just the worst
like I I wish I could sit here and say
that you know I robbed banks to fuel my
addiction or you know know I'd go beat
up a drug dealer I was a snake
um and I even the day that my
grandfather died bumper that I was
telling you about he meant everything to
me but the day that he died I waited for
my whole family to leave my house so
that I could go and steal my my
grandmother's checkbook um to write
myself some checks to make sure I could
have drugs um so it brought me to living
in my car um which at the time I still
thought that I was okay because I had a
place a warm thing to sleep in um the
car which my grandfather left
me
um what made me
stop or what opened my mind to the
thought that maybe I'm affecting more
than just myself because I was convinced
that that the only person I was hurting
was myself even though I was stealing
from you or you know not showing up to
my best friend's wedding or you know all
the things that we do I always thought
that I only was hurting
myself until I got
involved with the girl named
Julian I had known her from my childhood
she lived in the town next to me I'm
from walam she was from
Lexington I was living in my
car I had like 30 days clean and she
reached out to me and she said hey I'm
having a problem and I see that you're
clean can you help me and I said yes she
was living in California at the time she
came back to Massachusetts asking me for
help she came to Massachusetts we met up
I took her to some
meetings
um but in the end I ended up getting
high with her she was just taking pills
and this is another thing this is
another thing that um that I haven't
spoke about that no no nobody I've spoke
to people about this personally
oneon-one my closest friends are
therapist but I've never spoken about it
um so we started using together she was
just taking
pills I was a heroin
addict again she lived in Cali I was
acting so inappropriately but again the
selfishness of this of of what I was
doing so she was engaged
she was seeing somebody for four years
or eight she was engaged for four years
in California I had her fly to
Massachusetts and I told her that I
would help her I took her to some
meetings thought I was doing a good
thing eventually we started using
together and I knew that if I
could if I could get her to use drugs
the way that I use drugs she would need
me because she doesn't know how to do it
on her own and so I went down that road
I introduced her to the use of drugs the
way that I use drugs and she needed me
she
couldn't she didn't know how to do it on
her own she didn't know where to find
the type of drugs that I was using
um in in my in my
selfish storm you know I convinced
myself that like I loved her and I
wanted to be with her but really she was
giving me a place to live and she
was supplying us with
drugs she went back we went to treatment
together and we left and got High
um she went back to
California
and we would stay in touch she would go
back and forth but I was on the phone
with her one night and she told me she's
in California in Santa Monica is where
she lived I'm in Massachusetts getting
high talking to her on the phone and she
says I just ate my whole prescription of
colana
pins and I filled my prescription for my
pills will you stay on the phone with
me until I stop
responding I remember
thinking this is I remember thinking
this is so sad I remember thinking in my
head this is such a sad pathetic attempt
for a girl to just keep me on the phone
but I said yes I said sure I'll stay on
the phone with you
Jill maybe an hour it was between an
hour maybe an hour and 12 minutes
later she stopped
responding
um I thought she had just you know I
didn't think that I didn't think that it
was what it was I thought that she just
wanted me to stay on the phone with her
while she was getting high because her
fiance didn't understand we stayed on
the phone about an hour and 12 minutes
and she stopped responding the phone the
phone call ended the next
morning I wake up and I tell my mom hey
last night when I cuz I had brought
Jillian home my mother knew who she was
I said last night on the phone Jill said
that she was that she wanted me to stay
on the phone till she stopped responding
and that she like ate all of her pills
and I think she I think it was a cry for
help right after I told my mom that my
phone rang and it was from Jillian so I
got scared and I didn't answer the
phone and a voicemail was left and I
listened to the voicemail
and the voicemail was um a man and he
said I know who this
is I'm standing here with a coroner and
detective
um my fiance is dead and this is the
last phone number that she spoke to last
night she had it programmed as some
other girl's number but now I know who
this is if if you have any decency in
you call me
back so I called back
and the first thing that I was asked was
why couldn't you just leave us
alone
and I I I didn't know how to answer that
I
just
apologized for being
selfish I mean there's nothing you can
say on a phone call like that this man
fiance is
dead it it was a very it was a very much
harder for him I'm sure the phone call
I'm not I'm not it was just a very hard
conversation for me to have knowing
that so a lot of people tell me it's not
my
fault which may be
true but when someone says when someone
is asking for help whether they directly
say they want help or whether they say
this is what I'm going to do I could
have hung up the phone and called her
mother whose cell phone number I had I
could have hung up the phone and called
911 and said there's an emergency at
this address I knew what her address her
address was I could have called her
fiance I did none of those
things in some sense of the
word I hold fault in that situation
fault in not helping somebody who was
begging me for help fault for bringing
her down that road like I I in no in no
way shape or form do I think that I'm
Scott free like oh you know I not in
control of my my my actions it um I have
a disease you know what I do when I'm
high no it was I I made conscious
decisions to put myself in the
situation um knowing the
consequences so in some form of the word
I hold fault in that
situation that was the first time in my
life that I realized that I that my drug
use and my behavior is affecting other
people I I was so hard-headed that I
needed someone to
die for me to realize
that that my selfishness is affecting
others people and so that it was
December 23rd 2015 when that
happened December 26th the day after
Christmas I went to a place called mlan
Hospital in Belmont
Massachusetts and I hid in the bushes at
the front at the front door so stupid I
I I sat in the bushes and I did all the
heroin that I had on me it wasn't enough
I just nodded out someone found me it
was it was pathetic but
they sent me to a place called The
Phoenix House in quinsey
Massachusetts that place was was how I
ended up in California
um but there's a
very there's a very important person who
had something to do with my recovery his
name is Sean Sullivan one day so Shawn
got clean we used to use together Shawn
got clean he had a few years clean
and he took me to a
movie and I remember in the car he knew
about what happened with they I I told
him and I'll never forget it in the car
he said when are you going to
stop being a [__] basically when are
you going to stop when are you going to
like grow up when are you going to let
that go and that must have been so hard
for him to say that to my face knowing
how it affected
me but that statement that he made to me
and that question that he asked me
almost immediately took that excuse away
from me it it was
like someone pulled my covers and saw
what was going on and now I have no
excuse and I don't think I've ever told
them but
that forced me to take a look at my
behavior uh and I'll never I'll uh I'll
never be able to repay him for calling
me a [__] that day it was amazing he's
he's a great man he's still clean I
think he's coming up on something crazy
like nine or 10 years um good Irish kid
from walam
Sul
um yeah that the the death the death of
someone else is what made me start to
believe that I had some sort of a
problem
and I think that it is worth
noting that if in that situation I would
do everything the same
because I was so
selfish Mark I was so
selfish
that I was okay okay with her being
dead because that
meant that if I couldn't have her no one
could have her I wasn't going to be
okay and that's so that's so disgusting
and unfortunate that that I I remember
feeling that
way I remember
feeling at least I don't have to at
least I don't have to live knowing that
she's with someone else that that I
wasn't good enough I remember
feeling like in a selfish way like this
is the best way it could have ended up
because now I don't have to worry
about I don't I don't
know it's so
wild but that was
where that was where my my my addiction
took me I mean it took me to being
homeless I I've
seen being from Boston it gets cold out
there um seen people freeze to death
sleeping in the park and I've gone
through their pockets
um I've seen horrible things happen um
I've eaten out of the trash all the
things you
know all those I went to all those
places as
well somehow I've never been arrested um
I've been very lucky because I would not
make it in a place like that where you
have to like be tough and show um you
know spurts of of V violence to be taken
seriously that's not my that's not my gy
I'm a snake when I'm using drugs
um but you
uh I don't know if I'm allowed to to
talk about other people that you've
interviewed when I came to
California there was a man that worked
in the treatment
center and his name was
Hutch I don't I don't think that people
realize even you I don't think that that
anyone
realizes the
value that a human being like Daniel
Hutchinson has because that man didn't
know who I was I was just some kid from
the east coast and I remember him I
remember being teased about my accent
but there were a lot of people with my
accent there were a lot of people in
that program from
Massachusetts but Hutch at the time I
think he had about a year and a half
clean back back then this is 2016 and he
had his son he would bring his son to
work chance I think he was
four he would maybe he was younger maybe
he was two but he would bring his son to
work sometimes Hutch was in charge of um
reintegrating us into society so he
would take us to the beach or um you
know he would take would all Pile in
these these chuggy buggies the vans that
11 passenger vans and we go places
and he took us from Orange County to the
Redwood Forest up on the border of
Oregon it was a 17-hour drive he took 22
people two Vans full of
us and it's one of the best
trips it's one of the best trips that
I've ever been on
and
Hutch so when a man so when a
man goes through his life and never
hurts
anybody never does anything wrong never
steals you know doesn't do those things
and and lives a good life that's that
that's that's
great when when someone
is beat
down is is required to show violence and
force and does
that and Steals and cheats and is
cheated from and is beaten down when a
person like that knowing that they're
capable of doing those things when a
person like that chooses to not steal or
to not hurt people or to not
lie that is the that is the epitome of a
good person someone who is
capable
of
monstrosities and they choose to love
and they choose to be kind and they
choose to be
honest a person like that does not come
around very often
and I was telling it to
Hutch like none of us know how lucky we
are that Hutch has even existed this
long usually people like Hutch die very
young and we have been blessed to have
Hutch around as long as we have and I
don't think
people I don't think people use what he
has to their advantage enough because
I had a good friend Riley Kane who just
died in January he he was found he he
had five years clean and he was a hutch
he was one of those special people and
we lost him that's just how it goes we
lose hutches like Heath Ledger to to to
Hollywood this this bright um
shining everyone he affects everyone
positively everyone sees his light
shining and and usually they burn out
very quickly and
I think people need to realize that
those people are a blessing and they
should be treated as such I I I just
that man is one of the reasons Hutch is
one of the reasons that I sit here today
with six and a half years clean my clean
dat is June 6
2017 without Hutch I would not be clean
today Hutch was the one person at that
Treatment Center he was my North Star I
behaved as he behaved I I tried to talk
like he talked you know what I mean I I
just wanted to be wherever he was and
because he was in a good place then I
put myself where he was and I was safe
and I just kept behaving the way that he
showed me how to behave and and and
somehow I'm here um but so is he and I I
[Music]
just I know that you know how great of a
guy he is and how much he has to offer I
just hope more I hope more people see
that because he's in invaluable and
when when those people are
gone there's a lot to say after they're
gone and not enough is said when they
are here so I think I think it's
Justified to talk about how great of a
man of a human being that
hutches beautifully
said appreciate
that it's one of the coolest
[__] I've ever met in my
life absolutely scary scary you know I
great he's one of one of the only people
that you'll see dancing around and and
laughing and
then if needed to in in a moment's
notice if someone were to threaten you
or or look at you the wrong way and he's
having a good
time he will check that person to make
sure that they're not a threat to you
and then come right back to dancing
and and saving lives and I only know
about the treatment I know that he's
that that that he's a veteran and he did
a lot over there but I watched that man
positively impact hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of people in a treatment
center that was run by someone that had
poor
intentions but that didn't matter Hutch
took his small part of it and made it
amazing just like he does with
everything when he comes in when you see
him I bet it's I bet it's the best part
of your day it is it has to be it has to
be people like
that they
just that's why we Lo that's why we
typically lose them because people that
great are just not they just don't exist
you know it's
like I don't know man it's like he's a
unicorn he is and for you to have sat
him down and capture some of that and
and it's only a small part of you
captured such a
small amount of his
Essence to think that that is
only 3% of what he has to give the
world I
mean it it's I can't even comprehend it
he's impacted
me he didn't even know before I met him
for coffee last weekend I texted him and
said it would mean so much to me if you
could meet me for coffee I don't know if
you know
but you help save my life and his
response
was I don't know what I will have what I
could have done to have that impact on
you but if I contributed to your success
in any way means the world to me you
just made my year I love you brother and
for a man to be able to tell another man
that he loves him after seeing the
Carnage that other men can do and and
and and being punished for loving others
like you know he loves his brothers that
he's at war with and he loses loses them
and he has to go through that to still
be able to love another
person I I don't know what words to use
to describe
how immensely beautiful that
is word the English language does not
hold the right string of words for me to
ex for me to explain how amazing that is
meet him anybody that has ever seen
anything on Hutch meet him and your life
will be better for it
it's
true and because of
you mark he is going to have the
opportunity to love on a lot more
people I could have you know I could
stand out on Main Street in Santa Monica
with with a microphone telling people
how great Hutch is nobody will have any
idea what I'm talking about but now
millions of people know what I'm talking
about because of you
and I don't think
that just like I don't think Hutch gets
enough credit for the type of person he
is I just met you today but I don't
think that you get enough credit for
what this can
accomplish where it will go you know I
don't know but I know that if I were in
high school going through what I went
through and I saw this of me and knew
that
it happens and that it's all right and
that I wouldn't have gone
through age 13
to 31 thinking that I was not a whole
person I would have at least seen that
I'm still a whole person that just has
these experiences you know these people
that that hurt me did not take a piece
of me I didn't leave anything behind the
whole time I was whole I just just I
just didn't realize it I thought that
each bad thing that happened to me they
like took a little piece of me so then
the next person I met I was less of of
who I was it's not the case I just
didn't know that I I I I didn't
know I didn't know that I was whole the
whole
time these these type of interactions
with people and these type
of honest assessments of who I have who
I was who I am
um
it just
allows it allows other people to
understand that it's
okay that it's O that it's okay like
what happened to me is okay what
happened to me hurt and caused me pain
and then I hurt other people and cause
them pain I'm not saying it's because of
what happened to me I'm saying that I
chose to Ste in that because I didn't
know I didn't know that there was
another Jackie up out there I I I I I
didn't and my my good friends call me
Jackie I didn't know there was another
Jack out there I didn't know that I
thought that all the people that were
abused were
like on Skid Row which I've been there
I'm not I'm not saying that there's
anything wrong with that I just thought
that people who get abused either don't
talk about it and just live their life
as best they can quietly or they go off
the deep end and they just wreck
everything which I I guess I kind of did
wreck everything so maybe I'm not that
far off but if I had known then that
that that that people like me existed
and that it was okay to talk
about things might be very
different you think that uh not having
your father in your life when you were a
kid created some of this
problem I've been asked that question so
much um it's actually it's funny that
you that you asked me that I'll never
forget so I've been to 17 I've been to
17 different treatment facilities and
every time that I went to a new
treatment treatment facility I would ask
my my counselor or whoever was holding
the
group they probably got so annoyed I'd
say hey what's your definition of a man
everybody I'd ask other people in
treatment hey what what's your
definition of a
man hope I think I was hoping that
somebody would say something that I
could relate to but I just was so I was
just so ingrained with with feeling like
a coward and and I really didn't know
what a man was so I don't know not
having a dad my mom just my mom just
held it down man and and I had so I had
my grandfather so there was a man and I
had my great-grandfather for a little
while so there was a man in the house
but you
know the the youngest I remember him was
maybe
62 so like he actually you know he
helped me learn how to ride a bike um
but like by the time I was in Middle
School he's you know was in his late 60s
early 70s so for me to say like hey
bumper you want to come outside and
throw the ball around you know I'm
throwing the ball 70 miles an hour
seven-year old guy can't go out there
and and and do stuff like or he couldn't
maybe some can
um I think not having a
dad might have
left the door
open so
so I was talking to Hutch about
this Hutch always every time I see him
always tells me how beautiful I am so it
just bring Sparks conversations and I
and this time when I saw Hutch I said
you know
Hutch being
being
attractive is such a double-edged
sword it's gotten my foot into many
doors and and and given me opportunities
gotten me haven't been arrested probably
just because of the way I looked a lot
of times they I've gotten out of a lot
of situations because of the way that I
look and it's gotten me it's gotten my
foot in the door of many many
opportunities but it has also VI ently
swung open doors that I wanted no
business even going near anytime
something is is
is uh looks attractive or is shiny it's
not just people with good intentions
that are going to go investigate what
that shiny object
is would I I'm not
complaining by any means I'm I'm I'm I'm
completely happy with with looking like
a socially acceptable middle-aged white
guy completely okay with
that what most people don't understand
is that it comes
with like anything else it comes with a
side that is painful and that opens you
up to things that you really if you had
your choice you would want nothing to do
with um so I I think not having a
dad might have swung some doors
open um
that maybe would have been held closed
if if a dad was around I'm a single dad
now I have a 5-year-old son so
I so I really don't know what I'm doing
because I didn't have one um it's
actually quite interesting um having a
son and I take some of what I do from
hutch from what I remember from hutch
from 2016 with chance um and my uncle my
Uncle Eddie he was a great he was a
great guy but I I don't know what I'm
doing and and I just hope that
I hope that I'm able to to to just
prevent some of the therapy that I had
to go through for my son you know I
don't know what I'm doing he's a
sweetheart he's a great kid um he's
never seen me high he's never seen me
put any type of substance um in me that
would change my mind or my mood
hopefully that stays the case
um but not having a dad I think it
just
I did I don't I used other kids dads you
know I used other kids dads as as my
dads I thought I was like I think it
kind of made me feel unique you know I
didn't have brothers and sisters either
I don't know what that's like I just
like kept a lot of friends
around but yeah I used my my buddy's
dads as sounding boards
and not the I mean psychologically did
it probably have an effect yeah um but I
couldn't tell you what that is my mother
my mother did both she was she was great
she went to night school when I was a
kid to become a nurse I mean she
struggled you know I don't I
don't if I were from California I would
not be from Santa Monica you know I
didn't have it hard like Hutch Hutch is
a tough bastard he he had a tough he was
like 11 kids it was just me and my mom
so I was I was very lucky but having a d
definitely impacted me in ways that I
probably am not aware of
you had both parents right I had both
parents yeah yeah and and I see
how how important it is to have a dad
who kind of showed me how to do things
how to handle this situation wow that's
a really tough thing for a kid a young
man to
learn you you you learn it by seeing
your dad go through it if I if I didn't
have a dad I'd be a totally different
person I I think it would have been cool
to have a dad you know but I and that's
another like my selfish even when I was
a little kid I would get I would get
like jealous when my mom would go to
work be like you care more about the
patients at the hospital than you care
about me like I just didn't have a I
didn't have a balanced comprehension of
of of things you know through the and I
think I think that it has to do
with the stuff the stuff that was going
on behind closed doors you know because
it was I was four when it started
happening so like you know I I you don't
really know my son just turned five he
really doesn't know you
know can't really comprehend things like
he'll ask me what's the is there
anything bigger in the world than a
building I'm like yeah of course there
is yeah there's much bigger things than
a building so to to hear his frame of
references for me to think about you
know the array of sexual acts whatever
whatever you can you've talked to some
people on this thing that have probably
told you some crazy sexual stuff you
didn't know
existed starting to be exposed to to
those things at four years
old I think that had more of of effect
on me than not having a dad because no
but if you had a dad he could have would
have never never have happened yes so
and that's where I don't even see that
my dad's tolerance of [__] is
is like he he has no tolerance of
[__] yeah of any sort so when when
anything shady or questionable would
happen I don't know what that's like
that sounds amazing you know what I mean
and if I and if I had that my life
definitely would be different and he
probably my mom was either at work or
going to night school to become a nurse
to give me a better situation so it was
like you know 6: in the morning she she
did her very best but you still pay a
price cuz she's busy a lot but she and
and she did so great you know what I
mean to go to work from 6:00 in the
morning till
3:00 and then to go to night school
until 7:30 you know luckily my
grandparents were there but like what
more could she do you know what I mean
it's not like it's not like my
grandparents had a bunch of money so
they could be like no do less we'll take
care of you she she didn't want that you
know she wanted to make sure that I had
whatever I needed and wanted I always
had what I needed most of the time I got
what I
wanted but I yeah I I looking at it how
you're talking it about you know how
you're talking about it where like your
dad would be like no [__] yeah I
probably that probably would have been
really cool but I I you know I was I I I
created my own [__] so I probably
wouldn't have been wanted to call be
called on that either you know what I
mean I like kind of some kids are just I
like kind of be skate by they love to be
defiant
yeah having both parents must be cool
did did you ever pick like if you had to
pick one could you pick one pick one
what one parent like if if if if when
you were younger somebody was like you
have to live with either your mom or dad
I mean I was super super tight with my
mom yeah so I was
always I was so connected with my mom
that it was like there was no question
but I never had that never came up yeah
it's not normal that question never even
came up in my head yeah my parents were
married until she my mom died a couple
years ago my dad's still alive 95 95 so
you're going to you're going to live a
long time yeah his mom was 96 yeah my
grandparents all lived a long time which
is
scary he's he's he says he's going to
live to be 100 I'm sure he will that's
so crazy that's I don't know just at at
39 all the stuff that I've seen and been
through to think that to go through 60
more years is that is just wild not that
I would be making the same choices no
but by by being self-aware as you are
and and as Hutch is and as I am you you
I think you end up living longer yeah
yeah I think I think you you you
understand things better and and you're
not you're a
Survivor because you understand and you
you have a thirst for understanding for
figuring things out oh 100% I think that
I with my self-awareness I think that I
will live longer than you because even
though you have all that self-awareness
you still put yourself in in
situations that are really wild yeah I
yeah but I I you know I commend you for
that this these type of things
[Music]
are they can't be faked
and I don't think that you can put a
value on them because to the right
person I mean it it to the right person
it could literally save their life it
could make them understand that that
they have worth and
that to the wrong
person it's just another video uh of
somebody whining about their life but to
the right
person
it could make him believe that he's
worth something and then he could get
into a relationship and stay so that kid
has it
down it could cause somebody to to
realize that they're not the only one it
happened to so maybe they don't maybe
they don't need to take themselves out
of the world because there's other
people like them and they're
okay those aspects of it it
would it would you it would be a
detriment to society if you did not do
things like this knowing that it can do
what it has done for some even if it
helps 100 people but 10 million people
see it who's to say that those 100
people are not worth it yeah for for
every commenter for every comment that I
read saying oh you're just exploiting
these poor homeless drug addicts I get
five beautifully intelligently written
emails from people saying that like
you're saving my life you saved my life
you're helping me stay clean every day
of the
year I was a homeless drug addict I
exploited myself all the time me
standing at a gas station asking people
for spare change I exploited myself with
the sole purpose of getting drugs this
being done with the sole purpose of just
showing that it exists sh sharing
information showing showing what's
really going on it's a mirror on our
society
that's really what it is and some people
have a real hard time looking at that I
have a hard time thinking that there are
people that will go through their whole
life never meeting a man like Hutch
that's a tragedy Hutch I keep going back
to him but he's just I
I I will say that I pray that someday
some person views me the way that I view
Daniel
Hutchinson because
that would that would mean the world to
me because I know how high of regard I
hold him in if someone outside of my son
because I think he kind of feels like he
has to because I'm his dad but if some
random person or friend of mine held me
in the same regard that I hold
Hutch I would feel like a winner like I
did what I
was put here for I mean it's all love
really really what we're supposed to be
doing as a society is is loving up on
each other and helping each other
succeed is that the way Society is no
but when it all boils down sharing
caring about someone empathizing with
somebody having some compassion for
someone love is the answer and it you
know it's not used enough it's it's made
fun of a lot and it's it's meaning is
skewed by by society and movies but love
and actual actual human connection on a
level that isn't just like oh hey you
want to go you know you want to go drink
a beer yeah I'll drink a beer we both
drink beers no like like like a
connection like me talking about the
things that have happened to me maybe
someday I'll be walking down the street
or me and you will grab a cup of coffee
and someone else who you're about to
interview is there and they'll say the
only reason I'm doing this is because I
watched your video and then he does a
video and he shares something similar
with something different and then
somebody else at some point shares at at
a meeting at an AA meeting shares at at
at a church group that something
happened and that they're okay or with
your family yeah anything even with a
friend and maybe that friend's going
through the same thing and they're like
holy [__] me
too invaluable to and to not do that now
that you know that people see this now
that you know that this actually has an
impact to not do it would be a crime
honestly I don't plan on quitting you
can't now you
can't I I mean I think I think I know
what I'll be doing for the rest of my
until my dad my my dad's age you ever
think about interviewing your
dad I don't think he's as self-aware as
as like you are or Daniel or myself are
I don't think he'd be a great I don't
think he'd make a great video even
though he's got a hell of a
story
should think he was never that kind of
person my my my mom might have been my
mom would have been a great story yeah
MH but my dad's a great dude sounds I
mean he raised yeah yeah he raised a
great guy and you're doing a lot for a
lot of people Jack what would you say is
the most important lesson you've learned
in your whole life in my whole
life you've been through a
lot the most import most important
lesson that I have learned in my whole
life
um that I
am it's going to sound so trivial the
most important lesson that I've learned
in my life is that regardless of how I
feel and regardless of what others say I
matter that's not
trivial it seems so silly you you would
expect someone to say it's the most
important thing that we can all do yeah
it's just you know like you matter you
know what I mean I
matter we all matter yeah and it's so
important because for decades I lived
not believing that and when I actually
realized it it was like it was like
someone had given it was like someone
had given me the Powerball number like I
I felt like I hit the lottery yeah
because then all of a sudden the thing
that happened to me weren't so heavy
because I because I matter and if I
matter like the stuff
that the the you know the shoes that I'm
wearing the shirt that I'm wearing those
are just like accessories the things
that happen to me are just just things
but I matter like who who I bring to the
table
and my love that I can show someone
matters and and the the the best part is
you don't know know who it's going to
matter to and when so you just got to
always be loving because the moment you
stop there's going to be someone that
was needing it and you're not providing
it so that's the that's the that's the
rub you always got to be loving on
people life rips if you're showing love
and it comes back not everyone's going
to want to want to accept your
love do it anyway man yeah do it anyway
one of the things I think I mentioned in
one of the interviews I've done
on somebody else's channel is one of the
best things I ever read in my whole life
probably the best thing it was in uh one
of the course of Miracles books which
said uh everything we do is either an
act of Love or an act of
fear we never heard that once you once
you once you see that you have no choice
love Is Just except to be loving yeah
and
and realistically give me a re you know
give me a reason why you can't love I I
went through a a
divorce my wife had an affair we got
divorced I didn't want to get divorced
but it
transpired what good would it do my son
my ex-wife her new boyfriend or my or
the woman that I'm currently seeing who
I'm in love with what good would it do
any of them if I just spewed hate and
and didn't and didn't accept it for what
it is what good if I told my son when
he's like you know why don't you and
Mommy live together
anymore what good would it do him if I
started saying because she's this and
she's that and she did this and you
never you'll understand when you're
older it's just like we just you know
mom Mommy's with Josh I'm with Megan now
it's just the way that it is you know
and and it stinks that we have him half
the time and he has to go back and forth
but getting on his level and just
explaining it with love even though
there was a time where I would have paid
money to get on a soap box and say all
the things I hated about the
situation very quickly I
learned that it does nobody any good and
it makes me sicker so even I I just
can't understand what
situation love cannot help might not be
able to fix it but tell me a situation
that love cannot help or or influence
towards some sort of resolution and
I'll call you a liar because there is no
situation that that it doesn't help
that's exactly right I just I just wish
I wish that you started doing this a lot
sooner me too I should have started this
30 years earlier yeah like 95 would have
been great yep God all right Jack thank
you so much thank you I really
appreciate what you're doing it was a
great talk thank you Mark thank you
man